madame la ministre en ce 14e jour de
grève contre la réforme des retraites
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
commencent à publier leurs premières
statistiques qui mesure l'impact
économique de ce mouvement social sur
les commerces et les entreprises comme
nous pouvions l'anticiper 7 en région
parisienne où la grève dans les
transports pose le plus de problèmes et
impacte le plus grand nombre de nos
compatriotes que les conséquences
économiques sans les plus lourdes les
pertes d'activités déclaré par les
professionnels sont conséquentes et
elles auront dans les semaines et les
mois à venir des conséquences sociales
avec inévitablement son lot de
sensations d'activité de placements en
chômage partiel voire définitif
alors que le mois de décembre et la fin
de l'année représentent souvent une part
conséquente du volume d'affaires de
beaucoup de commerces parisiens
les chiffres de cette première moitié du
mois sont inquiétants moins 80% pour les
commerces situés dans les gares ou à
proximité 50% dans les magasins
parisiens 30% dans les hôtels avec une
cascade d'annulations 35% chez les
traiteurs 40% pour les cafés et 50% pour
les restaurants en moyenne près de deux
tiers des artisans ou commerçants
franciliens se déclare impactés alors
madame la ministre que prévoyez vous
pour aider les entreprises qui vont se
retrouver en difficulté au delà bien sûr
du maintenance